lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es que
podamos obtener un poco de experiencia y
ver unos cuantos ejemplos para poder
estimar una raíz cuadrada de números que
no son cuadrados perfectos por ejemplo
digamos que queremos estimar la raíz
cuadrada de 32 muy bien entonces en
particular esto nos va a interesar sobre
todo encontrar entre qué números enteros
se encuentra este valor de la raíz
cuadrada de 32 ok vamos a buscar enteros
que nos acoten por abajo y por arriba a
esta raíz cuadrada entonces pensemos por
ahora en el 32 si en la raíz cuadrada
muy bien y pensemos cuál es el número
cuadrada el psir el cuadrado perfecto
más cercano a 32 pero que esté por
debajo de 32 entonces podemos pensar por
ejemplo en 25 verdad esto es más grande
que 25 pero bueno 25 es
al cuadrado vamos a ponerlo así como 5
al cuadrado verdad entonces 32 está por
arriba de 25 pero x por debajo de quien
está pues tendría que estar por debajo
de 6 al cuadrado que son 36 verdad
entonces vamos a escribir esto como 6 al
cuadrado ahora bien raíz cuadrada de 32
entonces tendría que ser más grande que
la raíz cuadrada de 5 al cuadrado pero
la raíz cuadrada de 5 al cuadrado es 5
verdad mientras que tendría que ser la
raíz cuadrada de 32 tendré tendría que
ser más chico que la raíz cuadrada de 6
al cuadrado y eso solo es 6 verdad
entonces si solo lo pensamos digamos en
este sentido la raíz cuadrada de 32 al
elevarla al cuadrado nos da 32 5 al
elevarlo al cuadrado nos da 5 al
cuadrado y 6 al elevarlo al cuadrado nos
da 6 al cuadrado entonces lo importante
es que las desigualdades
que se conservan verdad entonces como la
raíz cuadrada de 32 se encuentra entre 5
y 6 podríamos decir que es
aproximadamente 5 punto algo vamos a ver
otro ejemplo digamos que queremos
estimar digamos que queremos estimar la
raíz cuadrada de 55 muy bien entonces
vamos a utilizar la misma técnica
digamos pensemos ahora en 55 si digamos
que eliminamos por un momento la raíz
cuadrada entonces cuál es el cuadrado
perfecto más cercano que se encuentra
por debajo de 55 entonces por ejemplo
tenemos que 5 al cuadrado es 25 6 al
cuadrado es 36 7 al cuadrado es 49 y 8
al cuadrado de 64 entonces concluimos
que por debajo se encuentra el 49 de
verdad que es 7 al cuadrado y el 8 al
cuadrado ya se pasó a verdad que es el
siguiente entonces esto será más chico
que 64 qué
8 al cuadrado verdad digo por supuesto
que también 55 lo podríamos pensar como
la raíz cuadrada de 55 al cuadrado
verdad es quizás una forma muy
complicada de expresar este mismo número
entonces como ya vimos estas
desigualdades son las mismas verdad la
raíz cuadrada de 55 será más grande que
la raíz cuadrada de 49 que en este caso
sería 7 verdad sería más grande que 7 y
sería más chico que la raíz cuadrada de
64 que en este caso sería 8 muy bien así
que esto es una idea eso es alguna es un
método de cómo aproximar la raíz
cuadrada de un número muy bien y esto es
bastante útil si no tienes una
calculadora a la mano vamos a hacer un
último ejemplo y como siempre te invito
a que hagas una pausa y trates de
hacerlo por tu cuenta
trata de estimar entre qué número se
encuentra en la raíz cuadrada de
123 muy bien
entonces vamos vamos a intentarlo con el
mismo método pensemos en 123 y veamos
cuál es el cuadrado perfecto más cercano
que se encuentra por debajo de 123 y si
pensamos por ejemplo en 10 al cuadrado
10 al cuadrado es 100 verdad así que por
ejemplo ahora si pensamos en 11 al
cuadrado 11 por 11 nos da 121 verdad
entonces 121 está bastante cerca de 123
digamos 123 es más grande que 121 verdad
y por otro lado 123 tendrá que ser menor
que 12 al cuadrado pero 12 al cuadrado
es 144 verdad entonces como hemos visto
estas desigualdades se van a preservar
acá arriba la raíz cuadrada de 123 será
más grande que la raíz cuadrada de 121
que es 11 y será más chico que 2 de
verdad que 12 al cuadrado nos va a dar
144 entonces si elevamos estos números
al cuadrado nos daría la línea de abajo
lo mismo pasaría en este otro
lo mismo pasaría en este otro ejemplo y
bueno ya lo habíamos notado en el
primero así que este es un método muy
eficiente para calcular la aproximación
digamos de raíces cuadradas quizás
tendríamos que ser un poco más
detallados a la hora de por ejemplos del
123 perdón raíz cuadrada de 123 a lo
mejor está muy cerca de 11 verdad porque
123 está muy cerca de 121 entonces
podríamos decir que sería no sé quizás
11.1 o algo por el estilo verdad el
punto es que este método es bastante
bueno para decir al menos entre qué
números enteros se encuentra una raíz
cuadrada